vsauce kevin here and this briefcase
contains the entire universe and
everything that makes humanity human
[Music]
yeah oh that's it this is it paper
dollar pencil sugar cube playing cards
rubik's cube let me explain
[Applause]
fold a piece of paper
[Music]
again
and again
a sheet of paper is about four
thousandths of an inch and to get the
number of layers after folding we make
two to the power of folds we start with
one then every fold raises that power
one more
my folding is not going well the world
record for paper folding is only 12
folds if we could fold it 30 times it'd
be thick enough to reach space 42 gets
us to the moon at 103 folds the
thickness of this paper would be around
93 billion light years so basically the
diameter of our entire observable
universe a piece of paper is the size of
the universe
[Applause]
and you're inside this sugar cube in
fact we all are or could be atoms are
tiny and their fundamental particles are
even smaller a proton is like a
femtometer one quadrillionth of a meter
the simple way to think of our body's
makeup is that atoms are a collection of
particles with a fair amount of empty
space between them quantum physics shows
us that's not actually true and that a
lot is happening and what appears to be
99.99999 percent empty space that space
matters but if we compress the atoms of
the human race into a tight ball and
ignored what's in between them all
nearly 8 billion of us would fit inside
this sugar cube this
is us
7.8 billion of us inside here we can't
all be unique right right no wrong
[Applause]
about 108 billion humans have been born
throughout history if you're one in a
million like my mom told me i am that
means there have been 108 000 humans
exactly like you
that's not good how can anybody possibly
stand out i know just do something no
human has ever done before like what
shuffle a deck of cards okay people have
done that but not the same michael
mentioned this in his math magic video
it goes like this you've got 52 cards in
a deck the number of possible
combinations is 52 factorial so 52 times
51 times 50 times 49 yeah yeah yeah all
the way down to one cool that's
that number different orders of a
shuffled deck every time you shuffle and
deal you've just created something
that's virtually guaranteed to never
have been done before and seriously
unlikely to ever be done again so ignore
your 108 000 clones opportunities to be
unique are actually everywhere and
there's no limit to what you can do
because you my friend you you you
watching this video you're a super
computer
[Applause]
this rubik's cube has six sides of a by
three grid and each square is one of six
colors the question is how many
permutations exist that's a good
question i think of it often the answer
is this 43 quintillion 252 quadrillion
three trillion 274 billion 489 million
856 000. that's it and every single
possible state of the cube can be solved
in 20 moves or fewer that's called god's
number and it took google 36 cpu years
of computing power to determine do you
shang solve the classic 3 by 3x3 rubik's
cube in 3.47 seconds maybe it takes you
longer but you're mentally capable of
processing any one version of 43
quintillion problems and solving it in a
surprisingly low number of steps you
solve problems in the world and if
you're like me you go outside once a
month to get more peanut butter and you
notice hey
there's other people around
[Applause]
this helps connect us but you've got to
think about it the right way this
doesn't actually have intrinsic value
money isn't actually worth anything it's
paper but it does represent a way for
everyone to exchange what they've got a
thing a talent whatever for what someone
else has the aztecs used cocoa beans and
the ancient chinese use cowrie shells
i've got a playstation i like making
videos and i want a pygmy goat it's a
lot easier for me to use something that
allows me to transfer my old playstation
and my video production skills and then
use that to buy a pygmy goat than to
find a pygmy goat farmer who really
needs a ps1 and a paradox video we have
a system that converts what we've got
into what we want and give someone else
away to get what they want with what
we've got and it's not just about money
currencies like love and trust and
loyalty spend nicely too you can be you
with
others that's why we're capable of
making incredible things
[Applause]
such as a number two pencil it's like
leonard reads eye pencil it shows the
sheer insanity of human cooperation that
results in making something as basic as
a pencil someone farmed the incense
cedar someone built the tractors for
that farm someone made the wheels for
the tractor someone mined the graphite
and clay for the lead others mined the
metal for the feral no one planned this
we just all did our little piece and
others combine those pieces with our
needs and desires to make a thing
everyone uses but no individual person
could ever make themselves we can't even
comprehend what's happening in this
sugar cube because it's too complex
where's my universe paper
[Applause]
we do all of this because we know what
zero is it's not even just nothing it's
the absence of value value that exists
somewhere just not where zero is if
infinity is so impossibly large that we
can't even really understand it zero is
an impossibly deep void we process
mostly by what it isn't we do understand
the power of something that's a
placeholder to make and identify greater
things but that on its own is sort of a
terrifying lack of meaning xero makes
the pencils happen and it's the absence
of pencils it's never getting what we
want it's never solving a rubik's cube
it's the inability to be unique it's an
action it's an empty
sugar cube it's
being in this
unfathomably large paper universe and
fighting against the prospect of being
and meaning
nothing
you know what it is but your everything
because you're not
zero
the world is big the universe is complex
and you can visualize conceptualize and
appreciate some of the most complicated
elements of life by
studying and researching and
experimenting but also by messing around
with some of the junk lying around
your bedroom or stored in your extremely
cool briefcase
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]